Oh almost kind of Wayne is almost that
what they don't we wonderful those darn
kids send me to buy monkey business
a man stop to fill out an application
for a job in the middle of being chased
by the police what you can't say that
he's trying to get his life together
what a responsible person she's trying
to get his life together he's like in
the middle of running from cops like you
know what I need to change my life and
he did it right that in there I commend
him for that how did he even do it like
did he run out grab the application at
Walmart [ __ ] start riding it while
he's running in a circle yeah drop it
back in and he ran out No
or is he on the run he was on the run
after no no active pursuit like like a
high-speed pursuit he gets out of the
car
files a job application drops it off or
did he fill out an application on his
phone online while on the run he applied
to be a police officer while on the run
oh no so I'll just show you guys the
video okay here's a video this takes
place in Massachusetts suspect Jose
Jimenez is caught on camera in a pretty
carefree mood as he asks if Osprey
Wireless is hiring manager takes him in
as into his office for an interview it
all seems to be going pretty well except
for the police presence swarming outside
interview to say the least they grabbed
him and he starts to tussle with him and
the other two come in guns in hand and
they said to him you didn't think that
we weren't gonna find you did you
I see who's doing I credit well this is
wanted for allegedly running over a
state troopers and what that was very
strange to stop last week it's not good
did they miss me hug him from behind
this is awkward just like that they miss
many spooked him he McGregor them
I want to be a little spoon that's
really good
yes nailed the awkwardness I use like
this - yeah and then you that's of a
team [ __ ] right there it's awkward
eighteen [ __ ] god he sounds like Louie
Armstrong is [ __ ] yeah he was just
running away he's trying to go into more
and more rooms like just be cool like
they're not gonna find me here
so he's wanted for assault and battery
with a dangerous weapon so apparently
what he did is that he ran over a
troopers but with his Toyota Camry in
the process event I bet you didn't hurt
that's a bad day they got them steel
toed boots because sometimes your foot
can get ran over but it doesn't do I got
my foot run over by my Isuzu Trooper and
I weigh oh [ __ ] I think he backed up no
good you know automatic no manual manual
so he has a manual so we pull up to
their house and then and she should get
she opens the door she leaves her but
right there next to the tire and then
Casey just lets go to break and so it
rolled back a little bit and then it we
can overcome what yes you know that
these circle things oh yeah yeah it was
bent okay no more fellas okay cuz she
was just like candy you're caught you're
caught you can it took like a good maybe
like six seconds for us to realize what
was happening and then I was like oh
[ __ ] you're on her okay I remember there
was one there was one years go-go
dancing at EDC like at the Coliseum and
there's always been this one go-go
dancer who's so [ __ ] overdramatic
like she's just one of those annoying
overdramatic
as in like she'll do like a backflip
slowly and then people like well that's
cool she has yeah
oh I didn't know you were looking it's
like
so she what run over by a golf cart so
you're telling me a whole [ __ ] car
ran over Jill's foot and she's fine
she gets run over her foot in a golf
cart and she's like on the floor shut
the [ __ ] up we know and then and then
like an hour later she's like in
crutches she's like oh my god with a
neck brace and [ __ ] yeah up on a [ __ ]
like pillow she's like kind of I guess
it was crazy like he ran over my foot
she's like yeah I was like screaming
frame we get off it's like dude it's the
same girl that I told you that is um
like oh she asked living in the house
with me and I asked if she is steady
income and what does she do she goes um
I'm a marijuana broker what whoa
so she sells weed so she sounds weed
that still doesn't consist of steady
income the marijuana broker if you're
not consistent there's the most
overdramatic [ __ ] I've ever seen well
I'm seeing her phones okay cuz it was
very much okay
just slap in the face she's like oh are
you limping
I think the way she was screaming it was
as if like someone was pinning her down
and punching her she was like screaming
kicking no golf cart that thing weighs
like not much and you had combat boots
on them I want to do that [ __ ] I want to
get like run over and just start
screaming up a [ __ ] bit but it has to
be from someone or something that has a
lot of money so you could do the doctor
dial technique yeah she was really good
at that she would be amazing at that
yeah yeah yeah but the way the students
caught was because one of the employees
at the wireless store they noticed that
there was helicopters a whole bunch of
police everywhere so then the employee
he goes outside while the suspect is
inside with the manager having an
interview I wonder the manager asks on
what Tunes only why is he so sweaty Oh
tip scenario I'm being chased by the
cops I did something really bad I come
to your house and I listen I need you to
hide me what do you do
me yeah what do I do
everything as a friend as a friend I'm
like listen like I just [ __ ] up on
something and I need you to hide me just
for like 30 minutes can you do that for
me something good did the cops trail you
I don't know I'm sweaty as [ __ ] though
you're in my house they're doing a
perimeter who can hear distant
helicopter yeah sure I'm gonna I'm gonna
help you on cam you're stupid you got a
kid think about your family but you're
my friend I'm a loyal friend you hire
them I'm gonna be like dude David you
better not brought them no it'll be in
the bushes because I feel like what's
gonna happen I'm gonna do that I'm like
can you hop again I guess I'm like you
are such an irresponsible mother now
imma turn myself in Corbin I'm still
comedian for sure you know like it'll be
nah it'll be like so will you help me
you say yes you're like you're a
terrible mother and you've been Punk'd
everyone and then all the cameras popped
up and then everyone's gonna know that
you're a bad mother now it's gonna be on
his channel
no I'm gonna be like you know what I
would did you came over you need help
I'll tell you exactly where to hide and
i'ma leave the house or you guys just
are in the backyard doing [ __ ] and I
just broke into your house just put them
in your clothes put a wig on and be like
this is my Abuelita she's here to visit
from Guadalajara I can't do crime like
that if you came in my house we would
immediately get in my car you would be
in the trunk and I'll have a getaway
back for you and we would drive off so
then when while the cops are in the
perimeter searching we already left what
did they stop you checkpoint they won't
leave the car running chuckling come on
run yeah I'm feeling boy save you you
know what it is leaving the house lawyer
David
do this for you but I gotta worry about
my future there you go just lock him in
your safe with a strong as a back-up
plan when they try to get me I'll put a
gun to your back saying I [ __ ] held
you Oh Abel I want you to come inside
your house they'll just come knock in
and say hey have you seen a six-foot
Korean man walking around no what if
it's like if it was me if they would
just follow the trail of potato chips in
a meeting ya know why would you be able
chips yes you really hungry yes get a
whole bunch of snacks on the right way
no and they would know that we're
friends cuz the the cops would know
about us on social media you know what I
[ __ ] hate it
job interviews so this is just a
question that's gonna ask you but what
is your biggest weakness no weaknesses
[ __ ] and everyone always I I just work
too hard what is the point of that
[ __ ] question I think it's Steve like
what is that it doesn't develop anything
it just makes you humble brag it's
[ __ ] dumb my biggest weakness is I
never show up what type like what I ever
say that in my interview it's [ __ ]
dumb that question I'm like okay acting
skills ready so my biggest weakness is
my son I'm just yeah I work too hard I'm
singing mother
I'm just so I'm too organized from my
own good I ask them what's the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you've ever done yeah
then one of them was like I'm so
embarrassed about this but one time I
threw my mom I think it was like 15 or
17 is mom's I bought him over and over
and over again and then like he grabbed
pounding on the door and like smacking
him and he was telling me how like a
really bad day and he just threw him did
he get hard
yeah pretty real
I can hear something fake or like every
I kind of improv with the interview so
like sometimes people I feel like
they're like way too square and I just
need to get to know them so I'm like
what's your favorite TV show I get in
the middle of like all the like typical
questions and then just to like kind of
catch them off-guard because a lot to
believe like over-prepared I just got to
get to know who they really are my
biggest weakness is that I could to the
west side with this one but I came yeah
gangster go like this yeah that's my
biggest weakness dude hey what's up guys
thanks for watching we are gonna
regularly start posting content on the
JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there the last video click
over here
[Music]